[Music]
Jimmy I'm just gonna say it I gotta let
you go
[Music]
you were just fired Oz let go for
liability reasons involved in insurance
the one-armed bartender I'm on your show
no respect Charlotte Motor Speedway I'll
know how they move the money
the only God knows anything about
blowing up real bank vaults is Joe bank
I am in car sir ring and yeah we got a
plan to get you a coca-cola 600 is the
biggest race of the year we need a
computer with us I know everything there
is to know about computers okay
all the Twitter's I know welcome to the
coca-cola 600 how many boards away is
evolved twenty yards
I don't favor 30 is it 20 or is it 30 we
are dealing with science here they're
gonna know what we want them to know my
life of crime is over
[Music]
that is massively stupid
it's gonna handle all this is gonna be
good that looks like it hurt
I want everything on Jimmy Logan I'm
about get naked
so no leak I said no bacon
you moment must be a simple nod in his
people sunny maybe will say that what
you get in my arm please
is it this one
[Music]